Think about three line segments like this and we have been
assigned a task to form a
closed figure using the segments How should we go about it We
adjust this one a bit and
place those two segments like this
Have
form using the three line segments This
is a triangle Let's draw it on a new page It's drawn
like this If
you look at the above figure you will see three
points which are called the
vertices This point is a vertex A vertex
in a closed figure  I simply find a point at which two
segments meet and to name the triangle What we have to do is name the
vertices Let's name them A B and
C This triangle will be called triangle instead of
writing the word triangle
every time we use the symbol  Of a triangle
instead the order is important here can we
call triangle b a and triangle c b yes we can but it is
possible we should try and follow the
alphabetical
order look at the triangle close you would see vertices
angles and sides to we have seen  That they have
three vertices a b and c We know that
an angle is formed when two
segments meet which means we have three
angles Here angle a b and angle c A
triangle is basically a three sided
closed figure with three angles in its
interiors and how  Many sides does a
triangle have 1 two and three three sides and it has
three sides or segments a b s and
c In this triangle a b s we also say that
b s is the side opposite vertex a and
similarly a is the side opposite to  Vertex
B and A is the side opposite to Vertex C
All this is very simple to understand but may get boring if you
don't know the real world
applications of
triangle Think about two brothers Ben and
Charlie who love breaking each other's toys Ben
has a rectangle  The toy is shaped like this and
Charlie has a triangular shaped toy Charlie
attacks first and breaks many of the toys easily Getting angry Ben runs towards
Charlie's
toy breaks it into two pieces but he realizes
that the tip of the toy is sharp and the toy won't
break easily if only  Try to Attack the
Other Two Sides and That's Why a
Triangular Shape is Considered to be
Extremely Stable in the Field of
Architecture So What Do We Do If We Want
a Stable and a More Solid Rectangle
Shape Maybe We Can Use Three Triangles Like This
And Make One
Rectal This figure will be more stable as compared
to this one
Most of the bridge you see will have a
triangular structure like this and helps
it withstand the heavy downward
force of the weights Crossing the
bridge Imagine you live in a town where  It Rains
and Snows Hellally What If You Had a House
Like This
in Cold Weather Snow Would Amulet on Your Roof
But If You Had a House with a Roof Like This Snow Would Just
Slide Down the Slopes This
Shape Is
Triangular You Live on the 25th Floor  of a
building and one day there will be no
electricity imagine climbing up a
straight ladder to reach your house that would
be really tough and to make it easy we have stays and
again is a triangular shape and because of all these reasons
and many more it is considered
The Single Most Important Shape in
[Music]
Engineering